[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec abdallah zekri président de
l'observatoire de l'islamophobie au
conseil français du culte musulman
bonsoir abdallah zekri merci d'être avec
nous a ajouté gilbert à bergl abergel
pardon président du comité laïcité
république bonsoir gilbert albert gène
merci d'être avec nous avant de
commencer ce débat en cette information
de dernière minute donc le sénat qui a
donné feu vert à un amendement de toute
dernière minute au projet de loi
précisément sur le séparatisme pour
permettre au préfet de s'opposer à
l'ouverture d'une école hors contrat je
cite soutenu par un état étranger au
style évidemment suite à cette polémique
aujourd'hui sur l'école d'albertville
votre réaction abdallah zekri
écoutez je crois c'est sérieux du tout
le sénat mais ça existe déjà
le préfet est là déjà la possibilité
d'interdire l'ouverture de l'école hors
contrat
donc c'est uniquement de la
communication comcom à chaque période
naturellement vous savez pour ouvrir une
gaule en contrat il voit l'autorisation
du procureur de la république celle du
préfet celle du rectorat et celle du
maire donc par conséquent déjà il faut
ces autorisations là et si parmi eux
refusent l'ouverture de nettoyage se
fera pas au travail maintenant je vous
dis cette communication de pickles cette
histoire de chat ce cas ci n'ayant pas
signé il ya naturellement
donnera pas de la partie certaines sont
politiques et la marianne qui est en
train d'être fait les écoles hors
contrats existent elles sont délivrées
pendant cinq ans et cinq ans elle
devient les écoles avaient contrat
maintenant je suis entièrement d'accord
s'il ya une école qui prennent le
séparatisme qui ne veut pas respecter
les valeurs de la république et c'est
quand la ferme si elle est ouverte quand
la ferme et si elles veulent être
interdit mais quand l'art est un petit
peu de faire l'amalgamme ça je ne suis
pas d'accord parce qu'actuellement
malheureusement on est dans une période
où tout ce qui touche à l'islam et les
musulmans
c'est bon ça rapporte des bois à rosy
gilbert abergel quand elle a écrit nous
dit de toute façon c'est de la
communication quentin si un maire ne
veut pas faire ouvrir une école privée
bel oubliera pas c'est pas exactement ça
manifestement vu la polémique de la
journée parce que le tribunal
administratif lui a dit bah si le maire
veut pas mais on a le droit de
construire du moment qu'elle permis de
construire c'est bien ça oui de toute
façon que je réfute totalement le
discours de monsieur 7,7 cette idée
d'islamophobie et de ressortir cette
agglo d'arguments de l'islamophobie pour
contrer toutes les toutes les
initiatives de la république pour
justement limiter à l'emprise de
l'islamisme radical
c'est absolument insupportable et ça
dure et ça dure alors ce n'est pas que
de la communication
en fait c'est un peu comme si le
gouvernement avait anticipé ou a répondu
très vite à nos préoccupations puisque
en l'état actuel de la législation il
était impossible de d'interdire la la
construction de cette école et vous
l'avez dit reine bahnou administratif
s'est prononcé simplement sur des
conditions dures urbanistique 10 heures
de parking et autres aujourd'hui il faut
effectivement accepté cette idée que
nous ne sommes pas suffisamment équipés
pour résister à ce genre d'intrusion de
deux tentatives de séparatisme il faut
dire les choses comme elles sont
le projet de loi actuellement en
discussion apporte un certain nombre de
réponses 1 dans le contrôle justement de
ces lieux de prière
il manquait ce petit élément qui donnait
le pouvoir dont pau au représentant de
l'état d'interdire de s'opposer à la
construction de tels de tels
établissements
pour des raisons qui tiennent alors que
j'ai lu le texte de l'amendement pour
des raisons qui tiennent aux relations
internationales de la france où la
défense de sa souveraineté
parce qu'il s'agit bien de cela ni
légaux russe n'en est pas à sa première
création il veut réussir un certain
nombre de mosquées mais le russe vers
d'autres écoles et ce qui est enseigné
dans cette école ce ne sont pas les
respect des valeurs de la république
on va avant de faire réagir dallas écrit
bien sûr on va écouter laurent wauquiez
il est un peu ce sur votre lit bien le
président a l'air de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes qui a dû être entendue
manifestement par emmanuel macron
puisqu'il lui a adressé une lettre
écoutez laurent wauquiez l'école serait
un établissement hors contrat dont
l'orientation consistera très clairement
à promouvoir des valeurs qui ne sont pas
celles aujourd'hui de la république et
qu'il s'agit de valeurs qui ne serait
pas en phase avec la république comme le
dit laurent wauquiez est ce que c'est
aussi soustraire à jeunesse turque eux à
la république je vais vous donner un
chiffre que vous connaissez certainement
mais qui dit beaucoup 400 élèves 1 sur
une ville qui en compte 1200 ça fait
quasiment un quart des élèves scolarisés
qui seraient susceptibles d'aller dans
cette école vous comprenez que ça puisse
faire peur si ce n'est pas conforme à la
république justement
je viens d'écouter monsieur sur le
plateau il a raison le milieu riche il a
d'autres écoles hors contrat et si c'est
qu'on les a été vérifiée j'ai été
contrôlé il essayait sait très bien que
ces écoles sont contrôlés une fois par
an avec des emprunts inopinés on
attendra les gens et jusqu'à maintenant
on n'a rien trouvé à redire
maintenant on a toujours le
fondamentalisme combat à l'intégrisme
je suis citoyen français contourne de
confier sa musulmane je tombe à
l'intégrisme
je combats le tourisme je compte pas ce
qui sert la mort d'autres pays
j'essaie toujours de lancer on les a
toujours dénoncé là moi je passais légal
ce monsieur mais rigoureuse dans un
terrain ils veulent construire un lieu
de culte
le maire sur le banc devant tribunal que
leur donne raison
maintenant il appartient au préfet au
procureur au maire et ses dires de
s'opposer
moi je parle uniquement sur le plan
légal on nous dit dépens de la turquie
vis ceinture que moi je suis français de
confession musulmane je suis d'origine
algérienne
j'aime la france moby je n'ai jamais dit
que je vais pas m'en biais d'objets déco
900000 du régime anéanti français je
suis désolé j'aime mon pays il ya deux
écoles hors contrat juive désaccord
contre à un catholique ça ne pose pas
problème était qu'il s'agit d'une école
aura pour des musulmans commencent à
trouver des histoires de parquer dessus
si des fois cela
moi je lui suggère où il ya des preuves
concernant la radicalisation de 1000 go
ruche il ya des preuves comme les
hobbies saïbi étranger à ce moment là on
est dissous gilbert est belle votre
réponse mais mais monsieur d'abord je
n'ai jamais contesté votre attachement à
la république je déjà bx je me suis
jamais jamais prononcé contre l'islam en
tant que tel mais enfin il faut être
aveugle pour ne pas que me legal c'est
quand même une officine qui est aux
mains qui ont en tout cas l'outil d'
influence du pouvoir turc actuel il faut
pas oublier que le président r doigts
lorsqu'il est venu je prends en 2010
8 a fait une déclaration disant mais je
vous considère comme qu'on ne touche pas
aux musulmans je vous considère comme
mes enfants que les ans les tentatives
d'intimidation sont multiples on ne
parle pas d'une école sous contrat enfin
hors contrat qui ferait qui mettra en
place des méthodes pédagogiques
particulière outre on parle d'une école
gérée par une association qui on le sait
on le sait les tanks est le long des
monts seulement démontré fait une oeuvre
deux d'intrusion dans les valeurs de la
république
c'est on est là dans dans la la
diffusion de valeurs opposées à celles
de la république
imaginez vous madame vous le disiez
quatre cents 400 enfants mais comment
est ce que vous voulez que l'enfant
puisse être 100 voilà voilà sur l'île
aux enfants comment voulez-vous que
l'école de la république trouve sa place
comment voulez vous que l'on fasse
société avec une telle initiative
comment voulez-vous que l'école de la
république
elle puisse trouver sa propre place et
alors vous parle effectivement de vous
aviez un vous parler de deux lois
effectivement notre loi aujourd'hui
n'est pas suffisamment structurée n'est
pas suffisamment complète pour éviter ce
genre de manifestation on peut se
référer effectivement à la liberté qui
aiguise au menu notre pays de créer des
associations
ce n'est pas parce qu'on est libre de
créer qu'on délivre aussi de perturber
les principes
avant de vous faire un verre avec vous
je suis d'accord avec vous on n'est pas
là pour perturber les principes y
expliquer moi une chose le milli gorus
et appellent encore trois quatre mois
ils étaient reçus au ministère de
l'intérieur
découvrir à 100 ils ont été
tu parles que ça m'apprend à l'elysée
alors qu'on m'explique comment ça se
fait qu'une association qui prend
l'avion soit reçue sous là naturellement
les faces de la république
cher monsieur vous savez comme explique
cette tombe explique cela alors vous
savez qui a été le créateur de milito
russe
je ne vais pas vous l'apprendra monsieur
necmettin à nice la liste antisémite qui
a été premier ministre en turquie entre
96 et 97 et a été ensuite mis dehors par
l'armée turque que le tout est et qui a
porté les valeurs de milli gorus très
tôt qui a un style et ses propres
valeurs
mais alors on sait parfaitement que la
stratégie de milieux russes
ce n'est pas d'apparaître comme une
association conquérante
c'est bien de se mouler un dans les
institutions d'en percevoir les points
faibles à ce qu'on appelle la taqiyya et
puis justement de quoi vibrer delà de
sept de ses règles de liberté de cette
démocratie ont donc pour un pour perdre
peu par v retire cette école pour
pervertir ses lois ce que tu as écrit
avant de faire réagir aux propos
justement de gilbert abergel je voudrais
vous faire écouter le maire
d'albertville un principal concerné dans
cette affaire puisqu'il s'est opposé à
cette construction écouter l'intention
affichée du cng est de créer une école
privée prodiguant un enseignement hors
contrats sur des bases et des valeurs
premières qui ne sont pas celles de
notre république
il milite en faveur d'une partition
territoriale qui polarise la vision de
la société entre nous et eux il est
urgent que le parlement adopte des
dispositions législatives adapté pour
permettre aux maires de contrer
l'installation d' associations ou des
entreprises piloté par des puissances
étrangères qui favorise une
cristallisation identitaire au coeur de
nos territoires
ça dans les écrits c'est quelque chose
que vous réfutez totalement parce que
j'imagine que vit votre fonction au
conseil français du culte musulman vous
vous connaissez donc ce sujet par coeur
pour vous minigo russe n'est pas dans
cette description que nous on fait le
maire d'albertville
non je suis je suis désolé de paris je
suis désolé il dit qu'il restait public
qui respecte je connais ce monsieur je
ne suis pas des bleus gauche
je ne suis pas du tout dans les
associant extrémistes d'ailleurs je vous
signale comme soeur de galles une visite
des officiels qui ne s'est pas rendue
pour toucher la rencontre je suis je
suis et dans ce que dans les analyses
le maire de 1200 je comprends très bien
sa réaction
mais vous savez nos centres de droit
tout ce qu'il dit ici devant un tribunal
à apporter les preuves de ce qu'il dit
de ce qu'ils avancent maintenant qu'il y
ait des noirs nouvelle pour contenir ces
secteurs aujourd'hui je suis désolé je
sais c'est de leur côté côté la justice
et le bourg côté gibert un verger cet
intéressant ce que ton dit abdallah
zekri parce que le fait et c'est que la
justice est effectivement de leur côté
comme vient de le dire le tribunal
administratif dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui on peut ouvrir une école si
on en a le droit donc emmanuel macron
selon vous vous l'avait dit en début de
ce débat bien fait de demander cet
amendement au ministre de l'intérieur en
sachant je le répète que ces écoles hors
contrat soutenu par un état étranger au
style comment se définit ton un état
étranger hostile après la diplomatie
mais je te rappelle ce que je disais au
début de notre entretien et que nous
avons écrit notre communiqué aujourd'hui
en état actuel de la réglementation
effectivement on n'a plus de moyens
d'interdire l'importation de cette école
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons appelé à des quelques précision
dans le dans le cas du projet de loi qui
est actuellement en débat au sénat pour
que justement le représentant de l'état
plus disposer
les moyens nécessaires à l'interdiction
de ce2 de ses yeux de ces de ses
créations là alors après on rentre de la
diplomatie comment faire pour qu pour
désigner effectivement l'état ça
reviendra daisy d'état turc comme un
état intrusif au sein de la république
ça appartient aux diplomates mais en
tout cas on aura quelques outils on
pourra le faire
abdallah zekri le mot de la fin ce qui
frappe ici c'est que le gouvernement
sembl emmanuel macron le premier semble
découvrir ce soir à la faveur de cette
polémique médiatique qui lie à ce
problème que finalement on peut créer
des écoles hors contrat séparé de la
république ou pas d'ailleurs que ça
comme vous lis tu sembles légal
aujourd'hui en france ils sont tous les
cas ce que dit monsieur gilbert je
connais pas qui était en train de
défendre le dossier d'une manière juste
qu'il faudra il a parlé de relations
internationales dans la salle des
pneumatiques
imaginez que demain la turquie le maroc
l'algérie la tunisie
ça va pas sous prétexte à ce que et des
bandas les banques étrangères qui sont
sous les ordres de l'étranger qu'en
france on fait quoi
mais il faut parler il faut parler
d'arabie saoudite
tous ceux qui s'achètent à part
milliards d'ici parisien les équipes de
foot c'est de l'argent détourné pour
acheter des immeubles
de fait il faut c'est la somme de
prometic mans il faut traiter le sujet
de manière peut-être le mot de la fin
monsieur abergel jeu peut que se dire
que c'est écrit dans cette déclaration
et man chassons l'argent sale par quincy
les temps dit monsieur mac on n'a pas
découvert le la situation au cours des
derniers événements puisque dès son
entrée en fonction il avait déclaré
qu'il refuserait de voir la turquie
faire en france ce qu'elle a fait en
allemagne
voilà donc ça fait un moment que les
services français interpelle le
gouvernement font des notes étudie
analyse nous avons des études
qualitatives et quantitatives pour
démontrer justement que ces stratégies
sont nuisibles à la halle équilibre de
notre réplique nuisible au bon
fonctionnement de l'est
de la république il était temps que
notre république se dote de l'arsenal
juridique lui permettant d'y mettre un
peu d'ordre
manifestement aujourd'hui la faveur de
cette polémique je le rappelle un
puisque cet amendement est un amendement
de toute dernière minute merci en tout
cas tous les deux abdallah zekri et
gilbert avait regel d'avoir été avec
nous pour ce face à face merci à vous
deux